Today is a special day
because this is the last lecture of
the FP101x series
on functional programming I hope that
you enjoyed
the ride and that you learned
how to apply the ideas of pure
functional programming
in Haskell to
your own programming language that you
use at work there's one thing
that we have waved our hands
about and that is lazy evaluation
and lazy evaluation is also something
that is
unique to Haskell. There are
other languages like Scala
that do have some form of lazy
evaluation
but the interesting thing about Haskell
is that everything
uses lazy evaluation
unless you make things strict.
And that's the topic of this lecture
is to give you a little bit of an
introduction
about the various possible evaluation
strategies
for functional programs.
Okay, up to now we have not
really looked at all at the details of
how expressions are evaluated
we've done evaluations
on the slides where we unfolded
definitions and so on
but we have not made this thing precise
and actually
haskell expressions are evaluated with
a fairly simple strategy
and the idea is that it's
lazy. Think about you being a lazy
person
The prototypical example is doing
the dishes.
I hate doing the dishes so I
want to avoid
unnecessary evaluation
I want to only
wash a dish when it's absolutely necessary.
Doing this lazy evaluation
allows us to program with infinite data
structures
because we're never doing more work
than necessary, even if you give me
an
infinite list, an infinite stack
of dishes, if I'm sufficiently lazy
I will only wash as many as I need so
you cannot catch me with that and
the other thing that we'll see
is lazy evaluation makes it easier to
compose programs
because there's never more work done
than necessary. And this
evaluation strategy is why
haskell is called a lazy language.
Let's look at some concrete
examples
and what we do to evaluate a
Haskell program
is to take a sub-expression
if we are evaluating a big expression
for taking a sub-expression there and
we are
evaluating that sub-expression.
And in this case
say that we have a function definition
square n
is n times n, now if we have an
expression
like that, square three-plus four then
we can evaluate this in two ways.
One is to first evaluate
three plus four to seven and then
we use the definition of square.
Substitute seven for n, then we get seven
times seven.
And then we evaluate it to get forty-nine.
But another evaluation strategy
is also to say: well we take square
of three plus four, we substitute
three plus four for n.
We get three plus four here,
and three plus four here
and then we
evaluate the results and we get
the same value. In that case
you might think: but now we have
evaluated
three plus four twice. And as we will see
Haskell has some smart ways to avoid
duplicating that computation.
Let's look at the first
sample, the first strategy.
We first evaluate three plus four
to give us seven.
Then we substitute the definition of
square.
n equals seven so we get seven
times seven and we get forty-nine.
Now let's do it the other way around.
We take this expression, we
instantiate n with three plus four.
We get three plus four times three plus four.
Now we execute this guy to seven,
we execute that guy
to seven and we get 49.
In this case we have first applied
square
before doing the addition but the nice
thing
is that the final result is the same.
Now imagine that there were side effects
in this code. Well in that case since we're
doing the evaluation
in different orders, the side effects might
happen in different order.
And the result might be different.
But since we're here
in the pure world it doesn't matter
in what
order you do these reductions.
That's a fact
about haskell: if there are two
different ways,
that both terminate, to evaluate
the same expression then these will
always give
the same final result.
And that makes it also easy to
refactor Haskell programs
because you can always
substitue and massage things independent
of where they appear.
And thats because of this
property.
Now we've seen two
strategies to reduce our program.
Let's talk about that in a more
general sense. What we do
is when we're evaluating an expression
there might be many choices
of sub-expressions that we can reduce.
We have seen in this very small
example, we've seen this already.
We could either first apply the
definition of square
or we could first do the arithmetic
on the arguments.
There are two basic strategies
to decide which of the expressions
of all possible expressions to choose.
And one
is innermost reduction which says:
the innermost expression that can be
reduced is always
reduced and then there's the
outermost reduction where you take
the outermost expression to be reduced.
And of course you can say
since this rule, we can also do random
execution we can pick
any expression to be reduced
but that's not very systematic right?
And that makes it
hard to read. It's kind of nice
to have a fixed strategy such that we
can reason about
its properties. And let's look at
this example here, where we have a weird
recursive definition. We define
loop to take the tail of loop.
Now what does that mean?
Well first of all
it means that loop must have type list.
And then we take the tail of the list.
This is a list that chases
its own tail.
And lets evaluate the expression
give me the first of the pair
one and loop. And lets
compare and contrast these two reduction
strategies.
Notice that when we
reduce this guy:
Loop equals tail of loop. Let's substitute
loop, so we get tail of tail of tail ...
of tail
so this thing actually
chases its tail.
And it will never find an
actual list
that it can take a tail, so it will loop.
Let's look at this guy.
The innermost reduction
takes the innermost reducible
expression
and reduces that.
In this expression here the
innermost reducible expression is
loop.
We expand
loop into tail of loop. Now loop
is again the innermost expression and
then we execute this.
This will not terminate.
This evaluation order
is too strict. It tries to
evaluate
the argument here of first
nside this tuple and then
that diverges and there's no chance that
we can
take the first of this pair.
Now let's look at the outermost reduction.
In that case we take the outermost
reducible expression.
That's first. It's applied
to a tuple which is a reducible expression.
First of a tuple A and B is B.
It's one, and we're done.
Alright, this strategy
gives us the result in one step
whereas the
innermost reduction would never terminate.
Okay, what are
some facts here? It's that the outermost
reduction
may give the result when the innermost
fails to terminate and this is what we
have seen.
And the second fact is that:
if for an expression there exists
a sequence that terminates, then the
outermost reduction also terminate.
And it will return with the same result.
If there
is any reduction sequence that
terminates, the
outermost reduction will always also
terminate.
That gives a strong hint that the
outermost strategy is not a bad
thing.
If there is any way that this thing
will
return a value in finite time
the outermost reduction will also
terminate. Now let's look at
a few other examples of
innermost and
outermost reduction.
And then maybe
throw some doubt on the
outermost reduction.
And this is our familiar example
with square. If we do the innermost
reduction
we do three plus four, seven,
seven times seven
forty-nine. This is done in
one two three steps. But if we do the
outermost reduction
we're duplicating that reducible
expression three plus four.
We're doing the work twice.
That's a fact
that outermost reduction may require
more steps
then innermost reduction.
But as we have seen sometimes
innermost reduction will not terminate.
Here's the crucial question:
Is there a way to have our cake
and eat it too? And it turns out that
there is. And the way
we solve this problem is by using
sharing
when we substitute
three plus four into the definition of
square
we don't just copy that expression
three plus four
but we share it so we have pointers
to that expression such that when we
reduce it once
it to seven, and now the results are shared
and then we get forty-nine.
Alright, and that's what lazy evaluation is.
Lazy evaluation is outermost reduction
plus sharing. Lazy evaluation
it's like having your cake and eating it
too.
And Haskell uses lazy evaluation.
Here's another example
that shows the advantages of lazy
evaluation.
By defining a
recursive type of list, a recursive value.
I should say of List. List is off
course a recursive type but we're
looking here
at a recursive value. We define the
list,
the infinite list of ones as:
ones cons ones. Let's unfold the
recursion a couple of times. We see that
ones is ones cons ones.
Unfold it again, we get ones cons
ones cons ones.
Et cetera, et cetera.
Ones is an infinite list of ones.
Now let's look at the
evaluation of head of ones.
And what we want to do is we want to
compare and contrast
innermost evaluation with lazy
evaluation and you can already guess
what will happen. When we use innermost
reduction this is the same example
as with loop, we are taking the
innermost reducable expression which is ones.
we unfold it, we unfold it, we unfold it
so we never get around to taking the
head
of that list. Whereas this list is
already
in the shape where we can take its head.
It doesn't terminate.
Whereas if we use lazy evaluation,
head of ones
that's still not reduceable so we
have to unfold this guy so we get
one cons of ones. Now we can do this
and we're done. In this case
the result is one.
In general, the slogan of lazy
evaluation:
think of doing the dishes; we're doing
just enough work as required
to produce the final result.
And really, when we say that ones
is an infinite list, we're kind of lying
because ones is not an infinite list.
It's a potentially infinite list. Only when
it's expanded on demand.
And it's not expanded eagerly to an
infinite list. It's just the recipe
to create an infinite list.
And if you would do this
in a strict language what typically
happens is, you would say
this ones is defined using some form
of a thunk. You put in a unit arrow
somewhere
to stop the evaluation because that
function unit arrow
is already a value. Now let's look at the
next example here.
We mentioned that, lazy evaluation
makes code
more modular and the reason is that it's
because
it does just enough evaluation to
make the next step. Let's look at
take five of ones.
That will return a list of five ones.
And ones is really the same
as this expression here.
The infinite list of ones
and that also returns five ones.
And again, the reason is that we have
seen that take was defined by induction
over the structure of the list.
Every time that ones
pattern matches on that list
it's evaluated just enough to
get the next value such that we nicely
terminate here. This is the end of
Part [one]
about lazy evaluation, see you in a
few minutes.